- Ready?
♪ ♪ ♪
- Peu importe l'activité qu'il
pratique, Mendy Levy, 18 ans,
ien se prendre en photo et
publier sur les reseaux sociaux.
- Mendy, focus, leave your
phone!
- Des images de lui arborant son
meilleur profil.
- You're looking good!
- Ces photos sur Instagram
constituent peut-etre pour lui
la preuve tangible qu'il n'est
plus prisonnier des Lev Tahor,
une secte où il a passé les
15 preannées de sa vie.
- la secte juive Lev Tahor.
- Affaire Lev Tahor.
- Un autre rebondissement dans
l'affaire de la secte juive
Lev Tahor.
- Le sort des enfants de
te Lev Tahor.
- La saga des enfants de
la secte Lev tahor a fait
la manchette pendant des années.
Le groupe s'était installé à
Sainte-Agathe-Des-Monts, le plus
loin possible des familles
israéliennes des adpetes,
inquiètes pour leurs enfants
et leurs petits enfants qui
vivaient selon les enseignements
de leur gourou excentrique et
autoritaire : Shlomo Elbranz.
- Bad memories, mostly.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mendy est né ici, c'est le lieu
où il a passé son enfance.
Une enfance peuplée de très
mauvais souvenirs.
- Non. Il n'était pas le seul.
Et la DPJ le savait.
DENIS BARABY, ex-directeur
protection jeunesse Laurentides
- C'est une situation pour
laquelle nous on intervient
depuis plusieurs mois dans cette
communauté-là pour des problèmes
importants au niveau
de la négligence, aussi
des enjeux de scolarisation.
- Alors que la DPJ s'apprêtait à
agir et retirer certains enfants
du groupe, les Lev Tahor
prennent la fuite par une nuit
froide de novembre 2013.
Direction Chatam, Ontario.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le Quebec demande alors à
l'Ontario de ramener certains
enfants sur son territoire, mais
l'Ontario refuse.
- Les 13 jeunes vont rester
en Ontario, ils ne seront pas
placés au Quebec car cela
risquerait de les perturber
davantage, selon la juge.
Pendant ces tractations,
les Lev Tahor, eux, préparent
une nouvelle fuite.
Destination : Guatemala.
- Et la Saga ne s'arrête pas là.
En 2017, Shlomo Elbranz meurt
dans des circonstances étranges.
Puis, en novembre 2021, deux
leaders du groupe sont condamnés
aux États-Unis pour kidnapping.
Ils voulaient ramener
au Guatemala des enfants
d'une dissidente pour les marier
de force. Mendy aussi,
on voulait le forcer a
se marier. Il avait 14 ans.
Mais l'adolescent échappera à
ce destin. Il réussit à déjouer
la vigilence des leaders de
la secte et quitte le Guatemala.
BRYNDEL GNIWISCH, mère d'accueil
- Nous avons une famille
très...loving, aimante.
- Aujourd'hui, il vit dans
une famille hassidique de
Montréal qui l'a accueilli.
- Et ils lui ont tout montré,
car Mendy arrivait non seulement
du Guatemala, mais surtout,
d'une autre planète.
- Il ne savait rien sur
le monde. Il ne savait pas qu'il
y en a une planète. Nous sommes
très heureux qu'il est avec nous
et qu'il est en sécurité, mais
il a sept enfants de sa famille
qui sont là-bas encore
qui endurent les mêmes abus.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le souvenir de ses frères et
soeurs, c'est peut-être l'image
qui hante, encore, le regard
de Mendy.
♪ ♪ ♪